[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on guys
what's going on
um no dirt isn't late it was a little
bit of a miscommunication
if you guys will
uh what happened is he told me that he
might be a little late tomorrow
so i was like yo
let's just make it to set of
make it till 5 15.
uh so no one's late
i put in the thing it started at 5 15
but you know i figured since i'm waiting
the the seven minutes for him to pop up
figured i might as well come coming here
and chatted up with you guys
let me let me pop in this
i need to get
the light above me working
uh he's not here yet he's not here yet
but he'll be here you guys know dirt
he'll be here
he ain't gonna leave you guys
a fool for too long man he know he he
wants
the smoke man he wants to talk about the
smoke i gotta figure out why my
accessories aren't working
i'll figure it out later though so
what's going on guys
what is what is popping man what's
popping what's up big mad mo
you know
what do you think of god award yesterday
you know
we're going to talk about that i got i
got my own opinions i got my own
opinions
i think you guys are going to like my
opinions well some of you
some of you
i don't know sometimes man i don't know
am i streaming the the video game awards
um
it's like five o'clock in the morning
fam
i don't know if i can get people
together for that
and the man of the hour
you know i might as well just be calling
you my co-host at these these days dirt
yeah i don't know what happened to big
you know we might have to rethink
bitcloud's contract
i'm gonna have to rethink big cloud's
contract what is some guest you guys
want me
and dirt to interact with
on the attic show man you know we still
building the attic show brian i feel
like it's doing well
i feel like it's growing it's definitely
growing
uh but what kind of guests would you
guys want to see
what happened to hustle we need his
motivation hustle got a new job and it's
demanded a lot of his time so as you
guys did you see this uh
dirt
on
nice the core controller
i need to put the blur on so like it
actually blurs when it's supposed to
uh so yeah uh microsoft sent us uh sent
me this to unbox and review well they
didn't technically say how to it
reviewed or anything like that i just i
hit up it's like yo
i want one
and they said it to me so uh
you know but i don't take anything
unless i do content uh word of advice
anyone in the chat
anything you get
you want to make a way of doing content
it don't matter what it is
you want to to put that into
your brand in some way shape or form
song of iron two look good to me i don't
know what did you see song of iron too
um i saw a tweet from the developer but
i really didn't look at the game
i didn't review that maybe i should have
so
let me hit the transition button make
the podcast look a little bit clean well
it's not going to really look clean i
got to do artwork you know i almost put
when i was branding this channel
it was it was revolved around me and
hustle i'm glad i didn't pay i'm glad i
didn't go through with that
so uh you know i got to get some artwork
made eventually
right now i'm still
i'm still hitting the corners man i'm
still figuring it out still buffing up
still working out still grinding got a
lot to do man we got a lot to do
so if you guys can tell let me switch to
the iop account so i can so i can
so if you go please
the time stamp police
stop mafia that's what you call them
right the timestamp timestamp mafia you
know
i gotta please them
they'll sacrifice me to the
to
to whatever deity they'd be looking at i
don't know
timestamp mafia
uh you know you either do what they say
are you gonna be six feet under
all right so as you can see
welcome to the attitude where we talk
about the past present and future gaming
i got my co-host with me
dirk griggty what's what's what's going
on dirt
what's up man how you doing bro
pretty good right now
i'm
tagging timestamp for 7 50 the show
starts because like i said man i'm
scared of you guys i'm scared of them
off you got to make sure
that they are handled correctly so you
got your time stamp for the show
starting
what games you've been playing dirt
what's going on here man uh
you know um it's that time of year i've
been playing a little 2k
i'm actually trying to go back and uh
finish miles morales i haven't finished
that game
um playing a little bit of that great
game
yeah yeah i'm enjoying it i've been
joining so far um what else i mean well
i finished things roll i finished that
last week so i still been playing out a
little bit trying to do some extra stuff
but that's about it man um still still
trying to uh play lost judgment that's a
long ass game so i'm you know
trying to grind through that one but
that's really about it bro yeah and um
i've been playing a lot of stuff here
lately to be honest with you
i've been playing
a little bit of
making fun of fanboys on twitter
i've been playing roasting fan boys on
twitter i've been playing reactioning to
fanboys on twitter it's been a it's been
a very
enticing day man nah
some dope games man so
where
so i did
pick this up
you know uh the the pokemon game oh okay
yeah so i got pokemon diamond now i
don't know why i got this because after
i got it i sit there thinking
the new one's coming out in like two
months so like
i i think i'm gonna stream the pvp i
love pvp and pokemon it's okay it's so
weird but fun at the same time you know
which we are going to talk a little bit
about the direct you know i know there's
people that don't care about the direct
me including one of them for the most
part
but
well like you can include me on that one
also
but i do think that the direct is
showing stuff that
we can't address because uh the direct
came out there and they're like we know
our audience and we're gonna bring it so
like i said welcome to the attic show
we're gonna go ahead and get on with the
show man you know we're gonna be talking
about bonnie ross leaving 343.
we're going to talk about square enix
letting they fans down
again
then we're going to be talking about the
playstation state of play we got a
little bit of topics in here talk about
the nintendo direct also talking about
that uh finally persona 5's been listed
on xbox
and so has death loop so uh we're going
to be talking about that
and you know i think
there's a lot going on right now
it's crazy how we go from one month
where there's nothing to talk about we
gotta wing it every week
and now
i feel like there's something to talk
about every week almost every week
and it's not just a little bit it's a
lot like a lot to talk about so
dirt
you're the co-host man tell me what you
want to start with first
well uh
i don't know man um
what did people really tune in and see
like okay we're talking
we got 11 minutes
we got 11 minutes in here man you know
we got a the the time stamp mafia we got
we got to get them uh we're gonna give
them 11 minutes on the playstation
instead of play so
let's talk about that first off put a
one in the chat if you have seen
the playstation state of play that was
yesterday if you haven't and you want
good laughs even if you have you want
good less uh iop definitely reacted to
it did you react to a dirt
yeah yeah my boy sean uh 786 did on his
channel so yeah we we reacted to it it
was it was fun yeah so there's plenty
place you can go and get some raw
reactions if you guys want to see a
little bit of banter between me and king
about gauntlet watch that afterwards
yeah i actually watch y'all y'all back
and forth that's funny yeah
it's looking spooky for him man it's
look it's what it looks like i have
officially
won and you could tell just like his
banterings went down
you could tell like he knows he's lost
he's just holding on it's like it's like
that that thing where it's like dude i
give him i give him out it's like that
pardon scary movie where the the dude
comes over and he's like grab my hand
and he's like no the other hand this is
my strong hand it's like i'm allowing
him out of this like just bend the knee
now we on a reaction maybe 150 people
watching i think it was like 250 but
whatever i mean do you want to bend the
knee now or do you want to bend the knee
on an iop with like 500 to a thousand
he's like dawg man i ain't been in the
knee till i see that game so you know i
offered him the out he didn't take it so
i'm gonna take his knee
in december or november november the 9th
uh yeah but if that game gets delayed a
couple weeks before it comes out now i
am going m.i.a i i officially leave the
iop uh community i will not be around
and i'll come back i'll be permanently
the addict with a c i will no longer be
the adequate fatigue uh so you're safe
though yeah i think i'm safe too all
right let's talk about this playstation
plate uh so do you know everything that
was announced there
yeah yeah
for the most part yeah what was some
stand-ups for you
well you know to be honest i thought god
award look incredible
um stellar blade looked damn good i
gotta admit the rise of ronin looked
good taking nate
look good um
is this something i'm missing those are
the games that really stood out to me
all right i know those are the obvious
games but those are the ones that stood
out to me so we got tekken 8 obviously
um
and i know kog felt like this was a lot
of cgi which it was uh no one's going to
deny that but i don't know why i don't
play fighter games so i'm not in the
trenches like that maybe you know
talking to like cognito okay mega these
people would know more about like the
fighting community i don't know nothing
about the fighting community you know
what i do when i play fighter is this
you just press the button yeah that's
what i that's what i do and i've never
felt like what they advertise as
fighting isn't the actual
like product i've always felt like
the people who make those games are
are really
down to earth and they don't really try
to like troll you with like bait and
switch stuff
so i'm expecting the game to look like
that so you know when you saw tekken 8
um first off it was funny how they were
trying to like low-key act like that's
an exclusive yeah yeah they always do
that and and it seemed like uh the
fanboys seem to think it does i mean
it is an exclusive also i saw some
people say some things about it being an
exclusive like no it's not in schools
it's a multiplayer
you know would have been crazy
if it wasn't exclusive because they lost
the street fighter that went for tekken
hey it's kind of crazy man like yeah and
tell me that's not something they would
do though like i honestly feel like if
they could they would
i don't think they can i don't think
it's an option
people don't realize that it costs money
to do stuff like that you can't
absolutely it costs millions of dollars
to make something that big time
exclusive um i think the reason they got
it so easy with street fighter is
because
at the time capcom wasn't in the best in
a bad place financial decisions
so
you could pretty much go in there with a
dollar and say yo what you got for a
timed exclusive you know i wouldn't be
surprised if like
if
if
you know sony went over there and paid
for everyone's dinner and got this
got a timed excuse obviously that's a
joke but you know
i liked it i liked it so um now it does
look like we got a demio for pr uh
playstation vr2
um those who don't know that's an
amazing game uh i have it on pc and i
have it on the
oculus
it is coming for playstation 5. it
wasn't just vr it is coming for
playstation 5. which is kind of like
annoying a little bit i'm like come on
microsoft i know that's a small game and
i know that's nothing like a lot of
people are going to look for but it's
like that is if i've never seen a game
pass game i've seen one there it's like
slide up there you know slide in their
dms offer them a little bit of money and
get that over on your platform because i
feel like that game
once they implement pvp because that's
their goal eventually
that you're going to see a different
audience i think that's going to have a
very
cold classic audience that it's going to
do really well did you ever play demio
no no i've never even heard of it bro
i'm sorry
it's like a like a board game like
dungeons and dragons type of things
actually iop actually
uh interviewed the developers it's on
the channel somewhere around there
so definitely go back and look at that
i'm i'm excited for it i hope it comes
to playstation xbox eventually now i'm
probably not gonna buy it for
playstation five because i already have
it on steam uh but it is a nice little
uh nice little thing man and then
this this is where
things got a little bit
weird sega comes up announces another
yakuza uh it's like a dragon issue
remake trailer
um i never heard about this game have
you
um no it's another uh spin-off
in the series right yeah apparently it's
someone's brother someone in my chat
said that i don't know if that how true
that is but one thing i will say is sega
comes out the next day announcing like
three other games why didn't they just
do that in this playstation show they
announced the next like a dragon yakuza
rpg they announced i'm pretty sure the
next game that's like uh the standard
yakuza's it's like why did you wait 24
hour maybe sony wouldn't let them it's
kind of weird you would only announce
one when you had access to all four
yeah
i mean i guess maybe because sega had
their own their own little twitch stream
and they wanted to have something for
their fans to be excited about
that's the only thing i can think about
i get it uh five dollar super chat from
the angry therapist md it was
playstation plus filler no delaying date
first party oh yeah all right we're
gonna get to that man we're gonna get to
that we're gonna get to that all right
so
it is what it is when it comes to that i
don't feel like there's a lot to really
go over in that uh you know they
actually did bring up the hogwarts
legacy getting an exclusive playstation
quest we already knew that they already
announced that
so i'm like why was that here
kind of weird you know it's kind of
weird i'm looking over these
and part of me starting to grade down
the scale like actually looking at the
list
because i gave it a nine out of ten i
think after looking over the actual
announcements yeah it might be a 8 out
of 10.
um
then they announced a project
renamed as stellar blade that looks good
yeah yeah it does it isn't exclusive to
playstation i had to see a little bit
more
if i feel like the game is going to do
really well
um i felt like it felt real
what's what i'm looking for
what's the work i'm looking for it felt
real dark so it was like
like in terms of the combat i felt like
like a faster sakura
but worse like a generic now you
now you talking about stellar blade
mm-hmm
i thought he had like a platinum games
like feel to it yeah
maybe
but i felt like platinum gains is a lot
faster than that too
i don't know like it felt like a little
bit maybe platinum games would be a
better uh analogy than than yeah because
yeah cause in my opinion it looks more
action than dark souls style game in my
opinion it looks more
platinum that will make criers to me
there's like a lot of action what would
you consider the difference between a
dark souls and a platinum game like
precision
um i would i would say uh one speed i've
never seen a fast
dark souls game
you know
tempo seems a little a little bit faster
and uh you know a platinum game i just i
just think about vanquish i think about
bayonetta that was a more speaking no
more faster like a lot a lot more action
in my opinion i feel you on that what's
up big cloud popped in i didn't even
know you was coming man
what's up what's up so what right now
we're talking about
the playstation state of play what was
your overall impressions of it
okay
you didn't say nothing oh you didn't
hear it um
uh no it was a it was a good show i
thought it was good for what it was um
for what it was oh oh it was but what
else cause uh
well really at this time i was expecting
a showcase not necessarily a state of
play but the fact they did a state of
play um now especially after that
abysmal disney uh showcase i was okay um
why i stay to play why not a big you
know ps5 showcase but uh we did hear
that there's more coming so i'm guessing
maybe they'll have a showcase of some
sorts in december or whatever i don't
know but
at this current time it does i don't
know
okay all right let's talk about the
elephant in the room let's screw
everything else uh two dollar super chat
donataku celebrate is a knockoff uh
bayonet i'm not gonna say it is or is it
uh i did enjoy what i saw let's talk
about that
yeah let's talk about the elephant in
the room yeah yeah yeah because
this game this this this state of play
which it was good i do think it was a
good state of play it was well paced
um
i do think because they announced a lot
of stuff that you wouldn't typically see
at a state of play
it felt like a showcase the end of the
showcase you know what i'm saying like
you know like they have that fluff at
the beginning of the show their
showcases and towards like the middle
and i just yeah yeah and then you get to
that end and they then they start
showing like a lot of the hardcore stuff
to me it felt like that it felt like
that is
that is the showcase this year i don't
think we're gonna get another
i agree let me say why i agree with you
i thought um they showed a nice little
gameplay site slice of god of war
i know the game drops in november
but that's something that trailer looked
amazing that's something you probably
would have shown at your your your
showcase right that ending uh yeah it
was incredible with the damn leviathan
it was incredible
i'm like they knew what they were doing
you ain't gonna hear me captain about
that brother
yeah that was like okay if you didn't
buy it you bought it now yeah yeah
you ain't gonna hear me captain about
that brother it looks dope
the controller announcement i think that
that was something that would have
showed at a sta at a showcase and also
you know
stellar blade and the rising ronin i
think those are two console exclusives
that they would have shown at a showcase
yeah state of place that's the reason
yeah that's the reason i think this was
their showcase for the year because they
announced a bunch of stuff we've never
heard of like most of the time with
these state of plays they give you a
little bit of both but
more
repeat stuff
of stuff we've currently seen in the
past then they they mix that with maybe
one new announcement and most of the
time it's a third party they rarely
announce
first party stuff at state of place like
as far as new ips
this one there was like what two three
like there was a lot like
that's why i kind of feel like
for people that we would say you know
it's crazy dirt we in september
and people really try to tell me in
december what's what's going on there
big cloud
what nah man cause what's name is in
december the game awards is in december
early december and the rest of the month
yeah do you honestly think they might do
another one
i mean i thought they were going to do
one day of november to go with god of
war or something like a state of play or
something before that but we got that
you know yesterday i don't i don't even
know what's going on at this point it
feels like a lots of got pushed back or
maybe they just had a compromise because
you know especially with the last of us
situation where the world literally
ripped that trailer to shreds or ripped
the game the shreds when they when it
got leaked so i don't know what's really
going on in the sticker case but
you know it's
do they need it that's the question you
know i mean do they need it after this
and honestly i do feel like we haven't
gotten that much out of them in terms of
updates on other stuff that people were
looking forward to like at the disney
showcase a lot of people tune in to the
disney showcase because they were
expecting spider-man 2 information it's
because spider-man 2 ain't coming out
next year let's be right here
it's going on next year for sure i don't
think
i don't think there's anywhere near
people i think what grades 225 i think
wolverine
2024 or 2025 that's that's that time
because if you think about it
like when have we ever
saw a game from playstation besides god
of war because most of the time
it most of the time they they don't they
don't mess with november they don't mess
with october they don't mess with it
they try to stay in like the uh the like
the late summer
early spring
time frame like for the most part they i
feel like god of war is the exception
not the rule
like i agree i feel like they wanted god
of war to come out this year and the
only way to make that happen
is that they had to go ahead
and launch it late and not early i feel
like
if we if star it may be spider-man's
different because spider-man is an ip
that could definitely hit in november
and not miss a miss a beat well when did
the original spider-man come out october
it's like uh yeah it's right now yeah so
i mean oh september or september
yeah i thought it was september sometime
part of me feels like we would have seen
gameplay on spider-man if it was coming
out next year
uh unless i'm shaving that for like a
big surprise for the start of next year
i don't really know but
but what if they ever done big showcases
at the beginning of the year
yeah cause usually around this time what
was it psx would be around this time
around december well
yeah i think psx used to be in like
october or something but they haven't
done it in a while so i'm saying the
last one was like around december-ish it
was around that close to that yeah yeah
it was around december so i mean unless
you got something like that planned for
a showcase like a psx digital event
i don't really know what's really expect
at that particular time and then um
going forward
you know
what do they do because right now it
seems like most of the energy on the
playstation side especially like well
obviously it's one guy who's like really
lopping against this but we already know
why he's lobbying against it and we had
this conversation multiple times and
that's related to the call of duty
situation that's what jim
and you know and talking to the regulars
like hey listen we don't think it's
right and it's like
jim
it's a wrap just just let it go it's
slack it's not going to stop
so
this is what it is
yeah i feel you man i i think part of me
at this point when it comes to this
is it's just like
we get it when we get it you know i
don't think a lot of people realize how
much the pandemic truly jacked up the
gaming industry yeah i think we're
finally starting to see remnants of
it getting a little bit back on track
and i'm not even talking like fully i
think
middle of next year is when we'll see
stuff slowly getting back on track i
think right now you you we just got
through all the games that were delayed
six months to a year
uh some of those games are still being
delayed and i think it's going to take a
little bit of time before we start
seeing stuff get back on track
in terms of
quality of games coming out that's why i
see seeing a lot of games you know
constantly breaking uh constantly having
issues coming out i think that's the
reason god of wars was internally pushed
back to november is because of the
pandemic because i think it
no pandemic this game would have came
out
maybe
april march may yeah like somewhere
around that but i think they're like
look we don't want to push it to
2023 but we don't because i feel like
they are like they saw starfield getting
pushed back as an opportunity to take
advantage of that november day i'm kind
of curious what do you guys think if
star voting get delayed do you think
that they would have done it you think
they would have hit a november day
i don't know that's a good question like
we're just speculating here but i'm
thinking probably
um
i don't know man i
i really think that i agree what you say
addict if it wasn't for the pandemic
them being a little behind it probably
would have
dropped earlier this year
but maybe
starfield being gone or you know like
postponed to next year maybe that
i don't know say hey guys let's hit
november
i don't know you know that's a good
question i don't think we really i feel
the answer to i feel like a starfield
came out
this game will come out the beginning of
next year like and it's not that
they're scared to start filled
it's just business you wouldn't you
would not put a big game
around another big game and if it was
the other way around microsoft wouldn't
either they would delay starfield like
you'd be stupid to go out there and try
to steal someone else's juice
when you could both have equal amount of
juice in two months from then
yeah a lot of um games were pushed back
in in response to uh god of war that's
why they pretty much gave god award just
this open window a lot of these
developers i wonder if harry potter was
pushed back because of god of war right
i believe because uh
it looks pretty polished it looks pretty
polished like it's already pretty much
done i'm day one in harry potter it
looks fantastic it's just um i think
they're looking for the proper like the
right month for that you know i mean
because how do you throw like what like
like realistically where what month do
you throw four spoken into
um
there's so many games dropping like a
lot of games that we see are going to be
after thoughts like especially when
games like dead space drop dead space
drops what in january in late january
yeah like january you got december for
kalisto protocol which let's face the
kalisto protocol is literally a lot of
people's top priority absolute
generation
january again you got another
um another piece of that puzzle with uh
dead space remake which is gonna lead to
part two can't wait for that to happen
and then you got um
the other games that were uh coming out
for spoken you got uh what else was it
they got pushed to twenty two harvard's
legacy
so you have a lot of stuff but you got
to find the perfect month for each
particular thing you know what i think
these publishers also don't want to have
two and again sony learned this as well
you don't want to have a month that has
four
aaa bangers in the same month of course
no you don't want that bro remember we
had horizon yeah yeah uh gran turismo
what else was in there elderly ring yeah
and it was one more what was the other
one it was like four it was it was four
games it's elder ring
yeah elder ring um horizon
uh the other one was uh what was the
other god
was the spider-man re-released it was
one of those it was like four games in
the same month the gran turismo
dying light two days in the chat light
too yeah thank you thank you so you have
four bangers in one month no no
publisher wants that nightmare that was
a nightmare for everybody nobody had
time to really process the game
yeah
yeah that's your background
yeah
ragnarok looking good for a 2023 game
oh
downtown
oh man
hey man i'll take you bro okay
today i'm levi at the next versus
mjolnir and like the lightning and the
use and the ice breaking bro that looks
do you think do you think that you're
going to get me or now after you defeat
thor oh you're on there ah you know you
probably will but it probably won't be
kratos who wields it i think this is
gonna be atreus's breakout game for what
the way they're shoot their way they're
telling it i think that bow and arrow
joint is gonna become a secondary one i
actually eventually like i feel like
i feel like
kratos will get the the uh the marinara
because what passed it on you think
once fire one's eyes it would make sense
lightning comes into play
i think what would be cool
is when they do pass a torch somewhere
way shape or form
yeah
atreyu
takes some of his equipment
like he doesn't take at all
i don't think he's going to take it all
but i think he'll take some you know
what he'd be crazy if they have another
game planned for atreus like he's taking
over
and the main antagonist has the the
blades of olympics
like he's the one that kills kratos and
he yanks that like i imagine they're
fighting and like they're fighting over
like he kills kratos and he can't like
he'll grab like his blades and he'll
kill him with his own blades and he'll
rip him off and then he's he's using his
blades on the trace and the trace is
like trying to get to his dad's body
just to get the the equipment that he's
got and he ends up with the axe
i mean from what we saw i think we saw
odin did y'all see that like that shot
at the beginning where do we opens the
door yeah it looks like yeah yeah he's
all like dark shadowed out i don't deal
with somebody
i'm not sure that's odin but
dude just the way they shot that even
with the mermaids like all the crazy
just references and shots that's like
dude this is like
very ambitious how they went about this
so i can't wait man
november can't get here soon enough i
really can't yeah
i was talking trash about that
collector's edition but uh that trailer
got me looking at that i'm your name
just a little different
i'm not i'm not buying no collector's
edition stuff
but you know what one thing i will do
is
you know i'm really excited for it like
god of war looks really good
i still personally think eldon ring is
gonna it's gonna take game of the year
you know ring is very high yeah you know
what though dirk you know what i
part of me is like if god of war is
better it deserves it but the other part
of me that toxic parts like i want to
see twitter
god of war comes out it's like a 95 96
amazing everyone loves it and then that
moment
that everyone sits there
and eldon ring gets called
by some no name i who who okay who won
it last year it was uh joseph uh joseph
what's his name because it takes two won
it so he'll be presenting
he'll be presenting it to the next
people because that they've been doing
that here recently oh man or he'll be
there for another iconic uh [ __ ] the
oscars yeah yeah and so
i think what would be crazy is
they say eldon ring
is it because it's just like look man if
there's nothing i don't even talk about
the regular playstation fans but i love
winning ups when a hardcore toxic
playstation fan gets upset i love it
it's just yeah
it just makes me so happy it makes me so
happy because it's just like dude we
don't have to sit here like like you
know if you want to sit there and bicker
back and forth people don't like like jw
i have a really good relationship with
jw yeah oh that's just jokes for j.w
he's not really like that in real life
and you know what's funny is i used to
have them on the attic show a lot and
people would
open up from the chat and say why are
you having this dude on why are you
having this dude on and then the same
people i'd read after the podcast would
put in the chat this isn't the same j
dub from twitter likes
so it's just like you know regardless
what happens uh god of war i'm pretty
sure it's gonna be a good game so let's
let's go and move on man let's move on
uh we uh
i'm looking right now
uh it looks like we're gonna talk about
the nintendo direct briefly
not too long we're going to talk about i
really want to talk about that yeah
because i i i i want to talk about it
i want to talk about and i don't it's
not that i want to talk about nintendo's
direction directly i want to talk about
nintendo and how they do the nintendo
direct like
i feel like they do a really one
announcement that was fire i think we
can give them that and that was the
golden knight
reveal thing that that was did you hear
about the
multiplayer yeah the multiplayer being
exclusive nintendo man how is it that
microsoft has all the bargaining chips
and they they leave with nothing like
they look like this
like that's a token surprise my dude
that's not even the fool
i did the full thing i just don't
understand how microsoft goes on with
all the bargaining chips and leaves with
nothing like they left with the game
okay
yeah well what does that really mean
when you can't play with people
like like we go from pla from xbox
does this stuff split screen the xbox
version
uh yeah yeah it has split screen you're
not online
you mean it to tell me that we go from
halo not having split screen to an old
ass game having it like it's just like
it's like dude
it's in the game they cracked it i think
what on pc they said they were able to
throw split screen or something like
that i just split it's crazy i just
don't understand
nintendo
they some gangsters when you mess with
them well we're going to take
banjo-kazooie and we're going to give
your people the last version of gold or
not like i'm sorry i'ma say this
i think phil should have turned it down
if you're going to give your consumers
the worst product
i think you should have turned it down
what do you guys think
i mean it is kind of the most pointless
like addition to the collection
it really is like it does nothing you
don't have you don't have the real like
main attraction towards it which is the
multiplayer so
i would say yeah i'll just turn it down
as well i think they should have turned
it down
um
yeah don't turn it down
uh because it's not it's not knight fire
bro that was knight fire i black gay you
know what take yeah i mean
bro we play that for the most part it's
a straight port
of the
of the like wasn't on xbox 360 i believe
um
and also read that um i heard i don't
know how true it is that the nintendo
switch version it it is online but it's
it's still like four player split screen
like i don't know bro see it's a whole
weird thing but i wouldn't turn it down
here's my issue with it
sure we get gold tonight 007
but we don't get
the most essential part of that game
which is the online split screen i mean
the online multiplayer multiplayer yeah
split screen worked back in the 90s
guess what fam we not in the 90s anymore
yeah i cannot tell you besides playing
games with my girl
i couldn't tell you the last time i
played split screen i literally couldn't
tell you like not even maybe the last
one maybe it takes two you think
well yeah yeah i played that king but
see i don't count that because that's a
game that was designed to be a split
screen and i played that online that has
an online feature i played it with with
king david
so it's just like to me it's just like
dude why did you even agree to that
that's that's so attritive like you're
going to give us the version and you're
going to give them sure they may get the
lesser version but guess what they're
getting a plate with friends
how is it that the the studio and the
publisher that have done nothing for the
online infrastructure of games get the
multiplayer structure but the people
that have done it doesn't get it that
makes no sense to me
nintendo just recently started making
like mario party and stuff online they
just recently started doing it and you
mean to tell me that studio is getting
to play with friends but the people who
pretty much made the foundation for
online gaming isn't getting it like i'm
sorry like
xbox
gets a big l for that they should have
said no we good we good we we should
have walked that's a reason why this
happens though
i saw somebody posted something on
twitter why
that that the xbox version doesn't have
multiplayer or whatever
so i don't you know me personally i
don't care enough but i understand what
you're saying but i don't think you turn
the game down because some people might
just want to play the campaign
i know it's the biggest part about the
game but yeah i feel you but i think
it's it's the perspective i i think it's
the perception it's like
you know at that point what's next what
like what what are we going to get next
that we can negotiate and get screwed in
the end
like how is it that microsoft will be so
friendly with place
with nintendo and give them like
banjo-kazooie but then they get like the
bad end of the deal when it comes to 007
go tonight like it's just like look like
it's not like
like microsoft gave them just banjo for
smash brothers they gave them banjo and
kazooie so it's just like why are we
getting half a game once again this is
half a game this isn't the the i mean
is it i i think it's lack of a feature
maybe not half a game is a little bit
being exaggerated because that feature
is there it's just a feature of online
it's just not a good look man it's not a
good look and i feel like
microsoft should have at least
negotiated a timed exclusivity maybe
we'll get it in the future i don't know
but it's just like to me
how are you going to let nintendo get
one off on you over a multiplayer game
that looks bad
over a multi-player game
yeah
i don't know but okay so we're not going
to really say talk too much about
nintendo's uh direct but i do want to
talk about zelda and the impact that was
going to have next year uh i think it's
tears of the kingdom i think that's what
it's called yeah uh let me go ahead and
get this five dollar super trap from don
otaku they
even i think the direct was a seven i
love jrpgs and farming sims that was
just way too much i'm looking forward to
all those games though i agree i
actually really enjoyed it i thought it
was one of the best directs they've had
in a while you know you got
you got fire emblem you got the new
zelda tears of the kingdom and you know
talk about zoda in particular
i'm looking at this zelda
and i'm like did they learn
and i'm looking at the zelda and i see
starfield coming out next year of you
know hellblade 2 most likely and i'm
like
can this game come in there
and just snatch
microsoft's very first game they can get
for game of the year in a while and
snatch it out of the jaws of a victory
like that's what i'm looking i'm like
how is this game going to pop up out of
nowhere
and take microsoft's
one of their only perspectives to get
game of the year for a couple years i'm
like damn ain't that a [ __ ] like
so what do you guys think about what you
saw about zelda and what do you think
about it's snatching game of the year
what
listen um
let me say this right quick big like
it's not gonna take long oh you're good
you're good
um
you what you say
you know zelda games always get a good
look that is always highly rated even
though i heard a lot of people saying
like they didn't like the last zelda
game
for whatever reason you know the weapons
breaking breaking
yeah a lot of people that i talked to a
person said they didn't like the last
zelda game but zelda is zelda it's a
huge franchise people love it and it's
always highly rated nostalgia nostalgic
most likely it will get nominated for
game of the year but at the end of the
day
i'm speaking for myself here
i don't give a damn about zelda farming
i don't care about nothing nintendo bro
that's just me nothing against people
that love nintendo but me personally
you're talking to a guy that you know
always respected nintendo when i was a
kid but i always had a sega
i didn't get into uh like nintendo until
the snes and that was strictly for
mortal kombat 2.
never a huge nintendo fan don't really
care about them but at the end of the
day zelda is a huge game
i actually watched some of the direct
while i was at work
um nothing interested me
nothing at all even zelda but you know i
it is a huge franchise
that's all i'm saying about that
what's your hate that's gonna say
piccolo
wow like that
i just i just heard dirt hate dance and
i got to hear yours
and i got nothing to shut you down with
i guess i'm just going to have to take
it man
he's so so gonna say i'm dead
so
that's like the nostalgia that held the
drug
nintendo will always get away with that
they're always gonna pass you know for
not elevating the game
no hold up hold up hold
without pushing the graphics of these
games and whatnot so you know these
games will always look the same addict
yes this looks the same as the last one
um
i personally don't feel like god
18.
i'ma just be real with you i don't think
it does i don't think i don't think
yours looks good how about that i i i
don't personally feel like horizon looks
drastically better than horizon two his
five is dlc the four how about that
well i wasn't talking about dlc you're
the one bringing up
just
do this for me man just
breathe oh man i knew it yeah
nintendo you know the title gets to wear
everything you know cardboard being sold
at 80 bucks or whatnot games that are
still behind and features
a concert that's lacking basic features
you know this game whatever uh that is
what it is will it get nominated for
game of the year more than likely yes
yes probably probably will get nominated
if and what was that game uh griggity
what was it uh mario odyssey
yeah
mario honestly which is pretty much the
same with that with a damn hat
nominated for game of the year on the
nintendo's side then yes zelda will
absolutely get nominated it will for for
a game of the year it will the next year
is that simple so that's my take on it
do i care about zelda i want dirt
riggity hell no
i don't get what they have about zelda
and i said it in the most nice positive
way i see that in the most nice positive
way if you like zelda if you're a big
zelda fan enjoy have fun hating ass
people okay we gotta fight all the super
chat from gaming forte
what zelda ain't snatching anything away
it's theirs to lose starfield is the one
that needs to be put up a great fight
zetta will win game of the year they're
gonna redeem themselves after that after
that original show
five dollar super drive from donald taco
tears of the kingdom is wiping the floor
with every game next year hashtag facts
two dollar superchat from flames sorry
y'all
s octopatch
2 stole the show and it's better i don't
know about that uh you know octopath 2
looking good but i don't know if it's
going to mess with no zelda so you know
we're going to go ahead and uh move on
with that because i don't think you guys
want to talk about that too much let me
put the 47.50 for the next one the 47
50 47. there you go
there you go
yeah i was thinking about that that that
uh
the scene and uh all about the benjamins
where he he's got the he's he won the 48
million dollars he's like foot no no he
he was he was rhyming at the cashier
making fun of the cashier reading his
stuff up she's like my oh yeah my my
girl got these numbers always playing he
starts like rhyming with the numbers you
can tell that cat she's like get out of
here yeah yeah i remember that part
so all right all right
let's talk about this square enix and
xbox man because clearly there's beef
that's beef there's definitely beef
right now we gotta find out superchat
from donald taku uh and breath of the
wild was not nostalgic it was the most
innovative open world game and zelda
fans didn't like it
uh
oh tears of the kingdom will eat what
will even be more of a jump so hold up
hold up
hold up hold up you're saying that
breath of the wild was not nostalgic
it was the most innovative open world
game and zelda fans didn't like it okay
so i agree with you that
maybe the only thing nostalgic is like
the master sword zelda link because
those are things that's come from the
previous things i don't think there's a
lot of older zeldas in breath of the
wild
but that name definitely carried it the
rest of the way like you put breath of
the wild skin on any other game it's
gonna get
demolished but you put it in
hyrule and you put it with the lore of
zelda and i think that's what carried it
the rest of the way but continue okay we
was talking about
square enix all right so let's say i
still won this uh no i see i i had i had
to talk okay
so how is that i'm trying to move on you
trying to move back uh this i'm just
looking at that i'm so we still on this
uh
over you know what nevermind
all right so
let's let's talk about let's talk about
score enix's
crimes against the xbox people
we're not going to get purchased this
pretty much all but confirms it yeah i
think at this point
that's what i saw
that's what i saw like
i would
i would be very surprised if sony didn't
have a
uh a verbal agreement to buy them at
this point dude like because look at
technique bro i guarantee you sony
squeaked up some deal with tekken 8 at
this point too like they're really
trying to go as for hard as they can for
multiplayer so yeah i can see that even
being the case
what type of deal with taking they
because they already like a minute
like mark like marketing oh oh yeah
after a little bit especially going with
evil being a big part of this absolutely
yeah that's going to be probably one of
the poster boys
ugly i think that's just like
just announce it at this point it's like
when i saw
octopath travel too don't come to the
xbox platform after
we have
the prequel
and it's in game pass
and i'm just like
how
the only thing that makes sense is
they can't do it because
daddy sony is like we don't care if you
put that on the switch but that xbox
that green machine
we can't know
we care about that you ain't doing that
and then situations like this that this
is happening behind closed doors that's
why i want phil to look at that call of
duty deal and rip that sucker up
rick that supper sucker up and say if
you want to play call of duty we got a
platform for you we got a console you we
got oh no a gaming console for you and
it's not a playstation it's an xbox
and if you want to play and i'm talking
about warzone i'm talking about all that
stuff rip all that you know what
actually it's gonna come to that it's
gonna come down to that petty one no no
this is worse dirt tell me this ain't
worse keep warzone on playstation but
never update it ever again what is all
playstation right now
but it's like oh by the way uh the road
map uh you know xbox can get 15. or
orange if you update it
have a season behind at all times
that would be brutal
imagine new people coming off and don't
know about this this this this this
fantasy ward i've made and then they go
to buy playstation to play warzone and
they're trying to play with their
friends and it just says it just pops up
and it says you don't have enough you
you have a playstation loser you can't
play
the wild part about it even though
you're joking the way jim's been coming
at phil's neck over this damn thing i
wouldn't be surprised if he did do
something like that like
like after they make their money back
from the game being multiplied
and literally can you know be okay with
it being on one platform
they can go to all they want they go to
that point one thing i do see them doing
imagine like because it says cross play
like
you they put like the energy sword and
like the battle rifle from like halo in
it if you get shot it's just it's just
empty like like you you see someone they
they running at you like yo what they
have and it's and it's there's nothing
there because they can't see it
and they just kill you with the energy
sword and they're like yo why how did i
die and this says you don't have a you
don't have an xbox so we're giving play
we're giving xbox people the advantage
you can't see their weapons oh dude i
could i could think of like eight
different ways to screw a replacement i
see yeah yeah
cool creative ways they can do though in
terms of content when it comes to guns
like imagine the halo weapons the doom
rifle was like that imagine if they made
a reach map and it was xbox exclusive
that's what i'm saying like there's a
lot of cool stuff they can do now
they're you know pretty much purposeful
you know
i got this over and maybe i got it the
ultimate game i got a different you know
how back in the day when you play plum g
and you would be jumping down this the
buildings ain't spawned you just see the
weapons everywhere and that's all
like you see the weapons in like the
second floor without the building there
and you can't and you can see the door
and that's all that's what playstation
sees when they play reach on playstation
they load in don't see no textures and
they played against people that see
everything actually that that might
actually
benefit them if they if textures and
stuff doesn't load because i feel like
in that case they could do some slimy
stuff you know what i take that back
xbox don't do that don't do that you
know actually actually xbox if you're
gonna do that put more textures on they
map
i want them to see everything the sun on
the sky i want to see
shade i want to see like the the glare
from the sun i want them to see
everything and have us not have none of
that nonsense you know when we look down
and we we're looking across the field we
see everything but when they're looking
across the field they see the glare
they see the blur everywhere they they
yeah you're
you know what playstation talk about
realism all the time
start giving them eye corneas and stuff
man start having them not being able to
see 20 20. they're gonna be far sighted
i can't see nothing in front of them oh
my god
imagine you you run into the field
and your contact come out and you have
to put another contact in in the game
yo y'all remember playstation all-stars
like when they had all those mascots
fighting yeah microsoft's in a good
predicament now they got call of duty
and all this stuff to make that what a
shooter yeah yeah they can do that
through this dlc with call of duty by
itself but yeah with the doom and
everything that's the uh the crazy thing
about this and this could be exclusive
dlc because it's the studios so i we
definitely went on a giant side trap
technically
yeah yeah yeah that was you addie that
was all you guys said
that was all you bro i mean you gotta
get us hey hey dirt you gotta get a slam
cause nobody yo tell me that wouldn't be
funny though tell me that wouldn't be
funny if playstation people had access
to warzone but they had like
near-sighted vision on the game they
their textures wouldn't load properly
like that tell me that wouldn't be funny
that would be funny it wouldn't be funny
long obviously yeah i thought it would
be funny if nintendo had a console that
was uh capable oh
if you had a zelda game that you looked
next-gen oh
[Laughter]
in the back all right we
occupied trump just like i'mma kill him
uh octopi traveler 2 isn't coming to
xbox what was your guys's thought
process
i'm not surprised
yeah
it seems like at this point um
it seems like uh certain games just
intentionally being left off of xbox i'm
not sure why
but in this case look man
there is gonna be purchased by sony
let's
let's just get this out the way bro i
don't know what's the hold up
um i really don't so
just you know
like well i'm going to say this last
generation this would have been no big
surprise at all this generation it seems
like a lot of japanese games are
starting to make his way to xbox
so maybe i am a little bit surprised
about this because as you mentioned that
it part one is in um
game pass
already so you would think that part two
would be
coming to the console so you know for
those that's into that's into that game
it's unfortunate on the xbox side so
yeah but i don't know man i just don't
know why he's not coming to the xbox
it is what it is at this point man i
think you know
it if you want to play japanese games
there are some available to you on xbox
but if that's your primary focus
just just go play a playstation with the
near side of people on warzone
yeah just just go play the playstation
yeah
as much as i hate to say that microsoft
can do with everything they can
but
the relationship sony has just gives
them such an edge in that part of the
world
like it's such an engine and to a point
money can't even buy that they can't use
money to fix that sure they can buy
studios but if the studio
owners and the shareholders aren't
selling you can't do that either
you can buy timed exclusives but if
you're not willing to give them the
money that they want which is probably
triple quadruple what you're willing to
give you can't do that either
so
my mindset's like look if you want to
play
ty if you want to play jrpgs
you know get a playstation uh because i
feel like playstation has a consistency
about
the majority of them go to there now
there are a lot to come to xbox you know
you are uh we have the tokyo game show
coming up tomorrow morning uh so we'll
probably talk about that on iop sunday
it's probably going to be my uh topic i
think i think my topic was something
else but if it's anything relevant uh
keep in mind you can always follow me on
gaming addict i'll probably cover it
there on a personal video but it's just
like even
with that going down
i don't see them doing
enough to make up for losing a publisher
like square enix in the japanese white
market um
sega i mean if they announced they
bought sega tomorrow that would be that
would be intense yeah that would be like
the only thing like i mean that would be
like the next strategic move logically
to make would be
how much
what do you think the odds of them
buying sega after this activision
acquisition is is wrapped up
it won't happen as fast i don't think i
think it'll be like a few years off
afterwards but i it's it's possible you
know it'll be funny if the reason it
took so long to get this
this activision acquisition is because
they've been buying both at the same
time
what oh
yeah they just announced
our acquisition for for activision's
done
but we we brought a friend we bought a
phrase
uh we
we have
sega along with it uh i feel like if
they bought sega you make
you make a world where
crash bandicoot banjo-kazooie
uh sega
you got stuff like uh mega man no that's
capcom
um
uh sauna sonic sonic you put them all in
the same world yeah
yeah they had their own all-stars type
of thing no no
like first you make a banjo-kazooie game
then you make a new sonic
then you make a cra
a crash bandicoot game
then you make a spiral game and then you
start mixing them together in the same
universe because i feel like all of
these characters could exist in the same
universe i mean sonic literally jumps
from uh from world world point on the
portal yeah yeah so he could easily do
that two dollar super chat from uh cal
webb i would rather than buy capcom than
sega i don't think they can buy likely
is yeah capcom is more inbound to
playstation than anything i could see
yeah i think that i think that would be
an awesome thing you know especially if
they just made a crack a crash bandicoot
spyro and banjo game yeah where you know
think of like the thing about sonic
though signing these like if they are
that was to happen it would need a full
like rehaul that makes sense because i
don't like
are you guys even buying sonic frontiers
i'm going to check it out but i'm not
that high on that i'm not
[Music]
can we just get like this classic sonic
like sonic adventures to battle type of
kind of kid yeah and there's an open
world like the world looks too big this
is sonic but it's not definitely think
about open world games and sonic too
because you know you got those little
little uh jumping pads stuff like that
the little things like that yeah it
looks it looks empty doesn't it like
what i think it's going to do good it
looks very i hope so i'm interested in
it isn't that
doesn't that game come around at the
same time the same day as
[Laughter]
it's just funny it's just like look
there's so many opportunities to see
people you know
the reason i say you start putting them
together you do like an mcu thing you
start
slowly building the lore in the games
you start like
name-dropping places and the other games
that they shouldn't be in i think if you
did that right and you built up that
anticipation and
imagine
being banjo
and you know you're fighting
crash bandicoot's bosses
you know it's something like that i
think it would work really well i i
honestly do you know i think another
good murder a good co-op game would be
not co-op game but two two people come
together would be jack and dexter and
ratchet and claim
yeah he's a little jack and daxter bro
yeah i think both of them two would make
a lot of sense like to come together
um and i even said you know
if they wanted just to stick to a
singular thing banjo-kazooie and crash
bandicoot both of them in one game
uh and what would be funny if like
banjo and kazooie get separated and
kazooies would
crash bandicoot like half the game
looking for banjo
and like imagine like the banter back
and forth i think it would be cool
wait skull and bulge is coming out the
same day as god award as well sonic and
skull bones what
okay ballsy
we've been asking for that game for how
long they grab the skull of those they
just like you know okay we finally gonna
give you the game but yeah we're gonna
drop it on the same day as god awards
yeah i don't i don't understand that
strategy i don't understand that
strategy right there that is stupid okay
yeah let's give you skull bones
i have less interest in skull of bones
than zelda i had you know here's the
thing though when we first saw that game
i know y'all remember because this is
when we first saw sea of thieves yeah
that's okay this is all right that's sad
how long it's been here it was like a
year after season remember yeah
the sea of thieves killer yeah
and that and now it looks like scholar
dude it's dead
d-o-a dead on arrival y'all because it
looked ambitious as hell we saw like the
cracking in the water nonstop it looked
great i was like okay this is gonna be
legit this might be to see if these but
you butch
i mean you can't get out the boat i mean
the ship at all on this one yeah you
can't at least
so wait only in sorcerers that means you
can't go to like a different
like island and dock yourself and go or
well i don't want to talk about that i'm
trying to get myself in trouble all
right so let's uh let's move on we're
going to talk about
persona 5 and death loop
looking like uh well persona 5 is on um
is on the
the store right now and hold on putting
the time stamps in for the time uh for
the time stamps mafia uh so and it does
look like death loop
is already showing up on the xbox store
it's actually showing up on my store i
actually saw it the way to see it is you
have to you have to pin
the store to your to your dashboard and
if you go to that pin on your dashboard
yeah if it will say death loop on it
coming soon or does it like it just says
priority pre-order okay so basically
yeah coming soon so i'm kind of curious
is it is it going to come in
[Music]
and for a pre-order is going to come in
drop stealth uh i think probably i think
it was on the stealth drop yeah yeah i
think i think probably the menu
in the game in the system unless it's in
the pre-order tab yeah so it's kind of
interesting man like all right first off
let's talk about death loot uh do you
think
it's going to be the the exact same game
we got with the playstation 5 version um
that's a good question i mean i don't
see the reason why i would not it looks
so you saw yeah it should be the same
game all around i don't know your accent
isn't going to have some enhancements
that's what i'm no i'm out here i'm
asking is it going to be is it going to
be a game of the year just like with
story content oh like one to one shot
like that uh it should be yeah hopefully
it should be if it's not then that's
that's gonna be that's gonna be weird
yeah i think it's gonna have everything
um i think the playstation version had i
think there should be a secret
assassination uh were you chasing down
gym dance move ryan
he's in a playstation
pc that looks like jim in a way so first
off who here's beat death deflate
i haven't played i'm waiting for it to
get on the xbox
i've
achievements over trophies so i was just
waiting for it to come to the xbox ah
she grew and i don't like you know shop
[Laughter]
there's actually a death loop
review on the channel for the people in
the chat that want to look that up
um
i think it's going to be just the
standard very i don't you don't think
can i get the ultimate or whatever
edition for this
you don't think so
i think i think it's going to be the
definitive version as uh i don't know if
that's fang
ent and it's like game of the year
edition or what was the game like
they'll probably name it game of the
year game of the year edition something
like that yeah i guess
i guess my mindset is
if we were going to get like extra
content with it to like entice people
that played it on playstation try it out
i feel like that would have been showed
at an event because that's a big thing
giving extra content
to me if you're just drop stealthing it
it's going to be the same port that came
in well
well hold on let's be honest they can't
show anything yet until is it the 15th
what's the day where is it like one year
from the day that playstation tomorrow
it's like hey maybe okay so if they stop
if they stealth drop it
why not hold on to it for a couple weeks
until like an event any event and then
show it then with the additional content
i feel like
they might do it but i feel like to me
the fact that they're going to stealth
drop it kind of makes me think it's
going to be just that game because if
you weren't going to stealth drop the
game if you had content
i feel like they would not stealth drop
that i get it if they had stuff to make
that game better than it's than the
playstation 5 counterpart they would not
stealth drop that they would go on the
next show and they would say look at our
room it's shinier like right i mean it's
definitely possible there'd be extra
attention what you're saying like yeah
like extra like fluff like a big
announcement or something or a tweet
yeah i feel like they they would do
anything they can to make it look more
appealing than the counter version on
their competitions platform
maybe they can't do it maybe maybe they
weren't even allowed to work on the game
like it would be kind of weird i don't
know how contracting things like that go
i wish they were more
transparent how some of these contracts
are i feel like i feel like
they do months in advance they just wait
for the deadline to drop it
these big corporations they're always
like keep all the info to yourself they
don't do themselves no favors
i feel like a lot of us would not be on
the ass as much
if we knew a little bit more what was
going on
like because to us when it comes to the
343 i know stuff about 343
that wouldn't calm people down but it
would make people understand it but it's
not public
so it's just like
if i understand it a little bit more
why don't you just make like
one of those things where
what happened halo infinite be more
transparent explain what's going on
so then people could say okay
up until now
that's the excuse they have let's give
them that excuse because they're being
transparent about it let's see what
happens in the future two dollars super
chat from flame what if death loop pvp
is exclusive to playstation don't you
terrorist say that oh no
you know what's funny
stop the flame you know what's funny
kids
have said this before
uh kids would beat death loot
and it's because we were you we were
we were misusing
the pvp aspect and i was helping him in
the game
like what's funny is you could go on
there if if you cut if you spawn as
julia and you can literally open up
doors for for call to go through
like
yeah you could literally go through the
there was a map where on the second day
or the first morning or something like
that uh you had to kill someone at a
pier that was in a room with like a shop
oh
and if you're cold when you kill her you
could open the door to escape
well when i was julia i just walked
through because they don't attack you it
just opened the door for smooth and he
came in and slit her throat and left
like
wow
that's crazy yeah so it's just like you
know
i'm gonna i'm gonna play it i'm gonna
play it again i'm gonna play it again uh
persona 5's on the is officially on the
store man any of you buying this
no um
it's it's in game pass right i'll just
listen i've never uh played played the
franchise i heard some great things
about it honestly from people i trust so
uh you know i might give it a chance you
know
you know i used to
i used to have this mindset
that said
they're putting in
game they're putting games in game pass
to be enticing for sequels and stuff to
come into the play the ecosystem
uh now that we have octopath traveled to
unless they announced that square enix
is buying them in the next like year
i don't even know anymore because my
point here's my thing okay we've seen of
yakuza uh we have seen yakuza games are
coming to game pass i come into xbox not
game pass so i think that was worthy of
that money
because you're getting the sequels in
your service now
when i'm looking at something like
persona 5 and it's coming to xbox and
game pass
my mindset's like
what is the point if you don't get six
when i see dragon quest 11 coming to
game pass
day and date i'm like
what's the point if i don't get dragon
quest 12.
and that
when you see stuff like octopi traveler
come on the platform
and you get excited because it's like
look i get to play it you're introdu i
would have preferred actually now
you not to even show the game at that
point
because it's just like
why
go above and beyond if you're not going
to make sure the sequel is on the
platform
so to me like persona 5 i think a lot of
people are going to like it's a good get
for game pass i think a lot of people
are going to enjoy playing it
but i'm on this standpoint if i don't
see persona 6 on gamepad i mean not game
pass but xbox not even game match just
xbox right day in day like when it
releases for others
and it's just like
you missed me with that
you missed me i need to see more from
microsoft when it comes to the
initiative of the jrpgs i've seen a lot
but when you have my when you have sony
that can make a phone call and strip
octopath traveler 2 from you
yeah i need to see more
you know and dragon quest 12
is coming i'm pretty sure that no i
don't i think when dragon quest 12 was
announced they never announced platforms
um someone looked that up in the chat i
might be wrong but i don't think they
announced platforms dragon quest 12
not 112 12.
i i don't see it
on xbox question mark
uh
no people are saying uh we can safely
assume it's gonna be
on uh xbox playstation so it's not been
formally announced
uh to me first off that's the scory enix
game
so anything by them is up in the air
but i do think
dragon quest is owned by another company
and they just make it
i don't think dragon quest is 100 owned
by square enix
to my knowledge someone else owns that
game
so that might be a loophole that they've
used to get that game but it's just like
look man
i love jrpgs i love them
and it's just like
i need them to do better you know if we
can't just think about how much
japanese like good ones we're not
talking about the the overall ones the
mid ones we're talking about the good
jrpgs the final fantasies the personas
the yakuzas like those type of games
how often do we really get them
you know we're not getting the remake
from tactics ogre
gone we're not getting the mega man
collectors edition i know that's a small
game but it's still a big game big
franchise people love gone
we're not getting final fantasy book but
gone but they'll give us final fantasy
crisis course i don't know what that's
about we aren't talking about that but
it's just like
we need to see more initiative
now since i saw because i used to give
them a lot of leeway i used to say look
they're doing what they can
but now after i saw this octopath travel
2
sure that might be the rule not the
exception
uh you know that might be but
i don't know if it's the exception of
the rule or the rule with not the
exception because i need to see what
happens to the next game if we get to
persona 6 if we get
the
dragon quest 12. for all we know tonight
tomorrow morning persona 6 could be
announced as a as an xbox exclusive we
don't know
but we got to see more
going to the future
if the sequels of these games coming are
coming like we don't even know if to my
knowledge we don't even know if kingdom
hearts 4 is coming to xbox right now
i don't think they've showed
platforms yet it is
so it's just like look like
thank you phil for getting me two years
worth of games that came out a decade
ago half sometimes
but i need you to do better in the
future not now
in the future
because if i have to wait two years for
a game to come out after it's already
came out what's the point i've already
played it on your competition
and that that that's that's my little
rant so you know what what do you guys
feel you know i know
dirt you said that you might try let me
let's be wrong both of you need to try
persona it's on gamepads
get no excuse yeah don't want to see an
hour stream of you in in persona i don't
know if you don't see that i want to see
an hour stream
we got a
three four three needs to do a
behind-the-scenes developer walk-through
like bungie did yeah people were mad
we're still mad about things but they
did a better idea of how involved and
complicated some requ some requests are
god of war did it and i get it these
companies it's hard to be transparent
it's hard
but it's just like
if you educate a lot of us influencers
on some of the ins and outs when it
comes to game development i feel like
you would have less videos
talking down and more like explaining
things if that makes sense right to 2.00
for cybu
xbox can afford the last imagination i
don't even know what that's about do you
guys know what the last imagination uh
i don't know
he got me with that one the last final
fantasy oh final fantasy because
fantasies and imagination i don't know
i guess he said with the last thing you
imagine you thinking about a battle yeah
i guess i i i don't know bro
being deep there man
was he taking shots i don't know yeah i
don't know what you were saying man you
might you don't have to super chat you
know
tell me what last imagine and he has in
parentheses makes me even more confused
like am i dumb for not knowing what he's
talking about
the last
the last imagination
i don't know man i don't know what that
means man
hey yo c will be um kind of um
elaborated before you know what the hell
that means and he's laughing hey man
that's not elaborating that's just
laughing brother come on man elaborate
man educate me i'm stupid right now i
want to i want to be smarter i want to
be smarter
um
you know so let's let's let's go on to
the bread and butter man the one that
every ball wants to do we had a we had
an hour
and 19 so i'm gonna put an hour at 20.
uh hold up let me double check an hour
19 minutes and and 35 seconds so you
guys can't come at me man because i'm
doing the best i can the best that there
ever was we logging as you know huh
aren't you logging them i'm doing live
i'm doing time stamps live okay now let
me explain to you why i do time stamps
live because i don't know why
you because you said big chat
they get upset when i don't do time
stamps live well when i do here's the
thing they want me to do time steps i'm
not doing time stamps unless they're
live because i don't have to go i don't
really listen i don't like i don't like
the sound of my voice i'll be real with
you guys let me roll with you i don't
like i don't like hearing my voice on
other podcasts when my girlfriend
listens to my pocket i tell her to turn
that [ __ ] down i don't want to hear
myself
so so it's just like you know you guys
asked me to go back and listen to myself
for two hours uh-uh
ain't happening it's all right let's
talk about let's talk about
bonnie ross
and apparently they had another person
leave today
yeah i don't know yeah
it looks like the management of three
four threes is finally changing uh dirk
i'm gonna let you lead this one man tell
me what you think about educate me
what's going on ah well fellas um it
seems like you know obviously you might
know things behind the scenes that we
don't
because you just kind of alluded to
something like that
it seems like um
what's happening it's just
you know like when the sports team they
they're they're trying to be better um
they're struggling a little bit even
though i still feel that um halo
infinite
the campaign was was pretty good in my
opinion the multiplayer while lacking
content the gameplay is solid right
um but
something's happening
over there
the game is you know i don't know if
some of the decisions they may ruin
griggity may be proud
something that's going on
but at the end of the day
i think
this was needed
i think some change needed to happen
because things just wasn't looking too
smooth
all right like i said like the gameplay
is pretty solid if you look at 343
halo 4
most people like the campaign but most
people dislike
jim pleasant the
multiplayer you know um
when it comes to halo 5. the multiplayer
is pretty solid but most people hated
the campaign
uh you know the whole debacle with
master chief collection when it first
released it just seems like there's been
a bunch of issues and you know sometimes
there's consistent issues you got to
look up top
and
sometimes you got to make changes man
because you're not going to you know
give this
this franchise to some other team that
people will say yo just give this game
the id software no no no
you just have to make some changes and
i gotta be honest guys i'm all for it
right now you know i'm saying because
i know if like bonnie ross
you know like she has some issues of
family issues some medical issues and
like i wish her the best
but as far as halo everything we want
the best for the franchise and we all
know the halo infinite halo
is a huge franchise xbox wouldn't be
around if it wasn't for halo
we need halo to be at the best that they
can be
and if it's not being the best that it
can be
there needs to be changes made and um
i'm okay with them man
so
watch me just saying that awful
impression of that song get copyrighted
what do you think big cloud
tell me what uh tell me what the other
side's thinking
i mean
it's funny um
once we got the road map for the content
uh for this game not too long ago uh
there's a bunch of tortoise faces all
over and one particular one i jumped in
i had to talk to paris about was the
whole thing but before i jumped in there
dudes was asking for
hashtag fire
bonnie ross
so
that she announced that she's gone
does this fix the game no
but at the same time
it's
i always looked at bonnie ross the fall
guy regardless of whether this you know
this is always going to be the fall guy
regardless
so the fact that she left and she said
it was due to family issues now this is
that's the only that's one thing i
question it's like she said i left
because of uh family related things now
usually believe because of family
related anything you get a leave of
absence you know i mean so i was like
that's weird uh wording the way she said
it but
again the game itself was not in the
best shape it just wasn't a lot of
people just thought it was going to be
better it was going to get better i
personally just like
from what we saw i didn't see anything
that screamed like this is the you know
the thing to look out for it just didn't
look like it
now that she's gone though
i hope things get better i really really
do
but i think
a few things should never happen again
especially for three four three number
one like a service game for halo
should never ever happen again they
should go back to their roots i think
and what's up i think a service game for
halo would have worked
but i think they needed
you need the more ambition they needed
yeah it's not even needed more ambition
like they have events they've always had
events infection grif ball they have
things they can do but it just seems
like
they want to do the carrot on the stick
route right yeah you're constantly
running for something but you're not
getting it but you're getting other
things in return
you know
you're not getting that you know they're
i when i look at the season pass for a
fortnight or like the season pass for a
destiny and i look through that whole
list i'm like yo there's a lot of good
stuff here what i was doing on halo i'm
like
what is this here's the um here's a wild
part about that though uh the you know
like all those other games that might
have events and whatnot to like probably
increase uh you know numbers or whatnot
they also have content
constantly like coming through for like
for the game whether it be a month two
months you know you got something to
look forward to for those games
fortnite's a prime example of this
it's sad that you got more deals but not
dlc you got more micro transaction skins
than you do in basic features and
content for hillary you know what they
should they should
they should have built
the slip space engine to be
is to to be very what's what i'm looking
for aggressive like you can change
things on the fly
kind of like fortnite they should have
built it to have an arena
for the dry hards
but it should have had a battle royale
uh in the map for zeta the map for the
campaign
should have been the map for the battle
royale and it should be transforming
like everything what's funny is like
they have a lore
that can make things like that like they
have a very massive lore like instead of
you know fortnite is weird because it's
like
it's it's like a game trapped in a box
you know
there's no lure behind fortnight really
it's just whatever they make it
like they have a lord
did you see that comparison they did
with uh halo infinite versus destiny 2
in the same time frame that it dropped
destiny 2 got
five times more content in the same time
frame that this game has been up
which has been like what two years like
two years imagine
it's no no no like halo
it's ten months like almost ten is it
ten months yeah yeah no it's ten months
it hasn't been a year yet
so
imagine the base game
you know the map of zeta wasn't really
hurt that much the ring
and that is the battle royal map then
you could still they still have the
arena maps that there are people working
on that but the focus is battle royale
because i think you don't really
it's hard
to survive in a games as a service
without
that
different gameplay every time sure you
have different gameplay in an arena but
i feel like it's not the same as a
battle royale literally you can there's
multiple places you can launch there's a
lot of things that goes into battle
royale so
you have that map from the campaign
that's that's the map now let's say the
next story happens and
let's just say
giant infection thing happens the
flood's back they destroy half the map
they
they make their own little fortresses
you go through there
now then what'll happen is you change
that map that you already made because
of the story
and then you make that the new battle
royale map
so you hit two birds
with one stone now i'm not a developer i
don't know i got some friends that i got
a few friends at 343.
i don't know if this is even possible
but it says like to me like
you know
let's say that
high charities rebuilt somehow the the
the huge covenant ship
and they can make that a battle royale
map but but here's the wild part too
though because the question was the
future of halo because especially in
these in those chats on
in those um twitter spaces and it just
feels like honestly once this uh call of
duty you know it's going back to that
division once this call of duty act
division whatever deal is done
it feels like halo will take the second
like it won't even be like the poster
boy for xbox anymore it's like legit
going to be like a third-party player
like it's going to be in the background
somewhere i don't feel like
halo is at that point where it's going
to be
taken as serious as it is
i actually think it will i just i don't
know
what's the content column
has to really
the content yeah it's true the content
has to really i'm going to ask you this
so why are people so upset
that's like
the road map why are they so upset about
lack of content
uh i mean let's see you get one because
they like the game no they like that
they like the game they like the game
they like the multiplayer for sure they
love the multiplayer but that's the
thing there's
not much here you still got party pretty
much party modes in the basic you know
when you want to play
other um other modes you can't
necessarily pick
a specific mode you want to play like
you can't pick like capture flag you
want to play capture flag or fake
you don't have that option you literally
have to play these little
group modes i
i got you yeah like people don't want
that i got you but
this is my opinion i think why people
are so upset
about the road map or the lack of
content or how long the seasons are
taking because
they love the actual game they love the
core of the game they love the gameplay
they love the multiplayer most people
love the campaign
it's just they're waiting for more
content and
some things that 343 has done with
saying yo this is going to come out this
day and then they'll delay it that has
pissed people off or this season is
going to be only three months this
season but it's hard to be eight months
ten months so those things are pissing
people off
but at the end of the day i think when
the content
comes on a consistent basis i think
forest is going to be a game changer i
mean at this point
i mean yeah well here's the thing about
forge ford should have been near day one
i i absolutely have that that should
have been a day one that should like if
anything if you couldn't guarantee the
you know the um
the uh co-op and on that stuff you
should have forge number one that would
inspire creativity people could have had
more fun with the game and just you know
kept them you know i mean kept the maps
going even if you couldn't reach the
demand of yeah newer maps you could have
had that stuff happen
but the thing is they didn't do that so
will forge
save it forge will definitely increase
some numbers i could definitely see four
juicing numbers but is that a point
we'll save it all together i
i think
foreign
you know that's the thing that's a good
question that's a good point it might
buy them some time but how much time
we're talking about here you know what i
mean like how extensive is this
how you know i mean are they giving you
that full yeah i'm like that that's the
that's the thing like i i don't believe
and i'm not even trying to come at them
like this right but it just feels like i
don't really have
that much fate that they can deliver
okay i mean that's fine i mean i mean
their their track record isn't great
um
let me ask you something but don't they
have a battle royale mode being
developed right now yeah so i just think
that um this
development cycle you know i would love
to know some behind the scenes
information about what happened with the
development of this game like what have
they changed engines what's up with the
slip space engine these are things that
i would probably never know but when i
think about the game itself
the core is very solid um they just have
to add the content on a consistent basis
in my opinion because people still play
the game now
once horde comes out in november um i
think that's going to be a game changer
we've seen some of the stuff people has
done already with with like some of the
maps incredible stuff
and i just think they just need to get
everything on a consistent basis and
hopefully this new
leadership this new management
can get things rolling how it should be
and i think once everything is rolling
in the proper way i think halo infinite
will be fine just my opinion but of
course i'm a bot so
yeah yeah all right so
always
here's the thing
the people that are leaving now
let's just call what it is most likely
it's the bonnie ross crew
um i don't see because it to me
if the game has been in a downward
spiral for a while i feel like people
have been protected
i feel like that protection
that protection window or wall or where
you want to say it symbolize it it's
gone
so now you're starting to see head rolls
starting to see people that have been
protected for a while
they're leaving
um maybe
this isn't
the reason that this individual that
left this morning uh
um his name was david uh
dave uh where's hold on david
the hell is his name i just had it
david berger
burger berger
so yeah so
engineering director yeah so you know if
he is the reason that
he was around so long after the slip
space engine was was was acting up like
we don't
we don't know exactly what's up what's
up with this what's up with that but we
do know one thing the game has been in a
downward trial for a while man i
appreciate it man you guys are being too
kind in the chat today uh let let me
finish my point i'll get to all these
super chats i really appreciate it guys
like you guys have no idea
all right so
bonnie ross is gone that's the top head
now i want to point out that bonnie ross
is not the sole single reason halo
infinite has been the way it is there's
a countless amount of variables
but
we got to be realistic when you're ahead
of the whole year though yeah when
you're the head of the studio
you're going to get more blame than
everyone else
so i don't know if she's the reason
is medical reason or not
that's really irrelevant at this point
if it is or not she's gone that's all
that really needs to be said
uh so
now that you have people that she's
probably been protecting
they're looking at that as like yo
what am i doing now
the people the chick that's been
protecting me is gone
so they're probably
maybe i need to find another job so you
know obviously
it's he said she said we don't know why
people are leaving but what i will say
and i think everyone can agree here
is
look does it look bad people are leaving
like this yeah but i think we can all
agree in the last year year and a half
dirt how many times people say we need
change of management
all the time all of us and now when
change of management happens people act
like it's a bad thing
no it's not no it's not it's not look
what you're going to get new ideas in
the studio you're going to get better at
least we hope for better direction but
you're going to get at least newer ideas
more creativity's going to be inspired
we need new blood in there and i think
that we are seeing it we don't know
who's replacing these people i think
they didn't announce she's replacing
bonnie but
yeah they did yeah who's your pleasure
pierre uh
[ __ ]
i thought you had this information let
me click it was a it's a guy he actually
um
helped fix master chief collection um
oh pierre
it was a black guy i can't think of his
name let me find it not that his race
matters but i'm just
[Laughter]
there you go pierre hence he was uh
he he helped fix the master chief
collection and that's what i need i need
results i need you to need results
look we do we know pierre going to fix
things of course now we don't know but i
know one thing
i was tired to see him
i was tired of seeing
one of my favorite franchises in his in
gaming history
being treated the way it was it's not
even the fact that 343 was doing it
wrong
it was a whole company all of microsoft
in my opinion was letting that brand
down i i i didn't like the tv show i
felt like it was a good tv show but i
had a good halo tv show i feel like
if you didn't know that they started
season two did you see it there yeah
filming season two well see you know the
ending of that corrected a lot of the
issues i had with the show
but i gotta see how they do season two
man i gotta see how they do season two
let me get some of these super chats
and uh
there's a lot man there's a lot i
appreciate the kind stuff today man the
kind stuff today
uh five dollars from el nino
it was announced today that the leeds uh
lead slip space engine engineer left as
well microsoft finally cleaning house
like i said
for a long time i've seen people say
nothing but we need to get these people
up out of here we need more blood in
there we're seeing that i think everyone
should be okay with that yeah i've got
this purge which is really good i agree
bro i agree ten dollars from ducks
ex
i swear you guys are changing your name
and super chatting just for me to play
[Laughter]
fortnight started
fortnite started as a horror mode game
horde mode game and didn't become a
success until they added a battle royale
mode halo has some time i will agree
with you haley doesn't have time
but
fortnight became what fortnite was
because they saw the success of pubg pub
g and they were like
i think we could do that better yeah
absolutely
hey man pup g it was huge man don't
people be sleeping on pubs epis it was
absolutely massive
i could i didn't see the iphone but yeah
it did have the problem yeah
yeah but it was just just that popular
that again nominated it was crazy
one thing that you can give
is that
you know fortnight there's not another
more influential games in the industry
like all of gaming industry like i don't
think the fourth wall i don't think call
of duty can touch it i don't think
wow can touch it i don't think no one
could touch that game oh duty definitely
touching that especially with that dude
no i'm talking like you put call of duty
at it at its at its prime
fortnight's still going to slap it to
next week which is
scary because it's ah that's wild it's
huge bro it's huge
all right so we got a a ten dollar super
chat from cal webb
uh big cloud called what called call
weep yeah called we call weaver called
uh call we
it doesn't matter okay uh big cloud
stop it you just praise destiny too
i get the idea
you don't play destiny because destiny 2
was in the worst shape at launch
the game didn't start to turn around
until forsaking
a year later hey how you feel about that
big cloud here i think he's pulling you
up man he he got he got he got the
sights on you man you got anything to
say that cobweb
what does that have to do
with halo infinite that launched i think
missing content i think it's going after
what you say i think what he's saying is
like you're you're taking up for destiny
2 a little bit oh no i'm not saying how
much content hold up let me finish he
that you that that you were saying about
all this content that destiny 2 had in
the same time frame but destiny 2 was at
a decline until forsaken and he said
you're not giving that same energy to uh
xbox and halo
adding you're additionally polarity you
can answer this though because i don't
really know he's 100 right it was it was
downhill until for a second so continue
continue bitcoin oh okay okay
okay okay how many modes did destiny
watch with
maps
content weapons
versus halo
features i don't know cobweb he might
have you there man he might have what
happened god what happened look at that
it's one thing when you move the
goalpost it's another you just say he's
saying you moved the gold post cobweb
what happened
we're gonna get it
think about this nintendo has a shooter
that launched with a great campaign and
multiplayer while having more maps
weapons on launch with new events and
content coming monthly and halo couldn't
i'm going to say at the end of that
donald talk before yeah
couldn't be me i i think he's talking
about splatoon 3. hey i think you're
talking about splatoon
hey hey listen listen come on hold on
for wait wait a minute brother
how dare you
compare some game with a five million
dollar budget
that was probably created in
one year and a half
we can't compare those two man come on
what uh i like the destiny comparison
that's more of a fair comparison but
splatoon oh look at that daughter
talking he's saying let's not do that
he's that's not
he's saying get that trash up out of
here we can compare like destiny 2
that's a valid comparison between
destiny 2 and halo infinite split yeah
that's fine don't go there bro splatoon
is too uh do you guys hear this yeah bro
let's do his layers though what's up do
you guys hear that
no you don't do you oh wait wait wait
i'm gonna answer which i heard something
what was that
[Music]
did you hear it
i heard that okay okay the the i think
that was supposed to be that you
triggered my trap card okay it is what
it is
well no like i got to figure out because
i like using this wireless headset i got
to figure out how to still use
my sound effects without using the
actual zoom for all you like i don't get
yourself a road caster a road caster
okay we'll go with that we'll go with
that so
you know taco
two dollar superstar from pic pixel bit
g so we forget in three maps and it came
from
big cloud come on man destiny 2 had a
pathetic number of maps weapons and
modes at launch
it had like four strikes it took forever
for balance patches trials was so bad
they canned it for 2.5 years but she's
right it used to be called charles of
the nine and they canned it because no
one was playing that snatch and they
named it back to trials of osiris so
what what is your what is your you got
anything are you are you submitting
are you submitting to cobwebs we no
because what is healing
actually it's got like nine maps to be
found what does that have nine maps and
what
uh it's got not a it launched with
ranked so we can put that hey destiny
doesn't have a ranked mode so he's kind
of got you on that should known
i'm not really into ranked bokeh and
that's it
yeah it it had big team battle
that's it
social playlists
okay
it had a full campaign built
how many weapons
there's a quite a bit of weapons in in
in destiny in halo there's quite a bit
i mean oh my gosh hey someone put in the
chat how many weapons
you know i think i could google that i
think google that you guys
look at him being messy making me use
google in the middle of a podcast how
many
weapons
does halo infinite have
questions
22 weapons 22 weapons
that's a lot
i think he has you i think you've lost
this argument wait i mean 22 22. and i
meet destiny
we can't compare destiny because they
have a bunch of room
shooters
you can't here's the thing though
hold up hold up hold up
hold up
hold it
it is it is a loot shooter you can't
compare a loop shooter on weapons to a
non-loot shooter game oh no what's
happening
right now
well i just i got i gotta agree
you got a cat for free okay i got you
okay cowboy okay no no no no no cobweb
might have you just because look man you
zero and one with cobwebs that's it's
not a big deal
but you said you could come back
i don't get it i don't know what would
you see road one with cowboys it's not a
big deal oh yeah i'm moving the
goalposts
sometimes you lose man sometimes you
lose you just gotta roll with it
you just gotta roll with it so you're
moving the goalposts
so you so just to clarify you said
you're moving the goalpost i don't get
it what is happening
[Laughter]
oh god
[Music]
i'm sure you want to move on actually
i never said it was a fair comparison
okay i was i was worried
i said there's a better it's a better
comparison than splatoon
that's what i said dirt dirt
dirt
it's confirmed yeah sure
oh man y'all crazy you guys are
ridiculous look like at the end of the
day you know let's do final thoughts on
this oh find out jeff from cobweb
destiny 2 at launch didn't have random
roads and we had a small pool of weapons
halo is a is not a loot shooter so won't
have
as many weapons as destinations and
you're quote unquote agreeing with them
then why the hell you bringing up
destiny comparing it to this
you specifically brought up destiny 2
you said have more content more
everything than halo infinite in in the
first year you said you just conceded
i'm gonna be real with you big cloud you
disappointed me today like i expected a
better fight from you but you know
but he came in here cat came in here
with the right hook he right hooked you
and when that right that left hook was
coming that shadow left hook he knocked
you out the reason that room is strong
let's keep it a buck almost not even
clean
the the reason that room is so dark is
because he knocked you out like five
minutes in there that's where it starts
you didn't you woke up came straight in
the podcast didn't even turn the light
on oh man y'all y'all hilarious bro
that's funny that's what you deal with
all right so let's let's get to like we
got to get up out of here so let's get
the last uh thoughts process uh dirt
lifestyle process on three four three
and all their management shifting
this is uh i think at the end of the day
this is good for the franchise
there there needed to be a shakeup i
know um some people like bonnie ross
i don't i didn't have a problem with her
but you know like you needed to see the
results and it was clear there needs to
be some changes and i'm all for it man
you know as i hope she's okay you know
her family and also david berger or
whatever he's fine you know but
sometimes you have to make tough
decisions and sometimes things need to
change
and i'm i'm okay with it
all right so big cloud
okay so three four three in the future
hey olympian it sucks caught well it
sucks trash
oh my gosh
that's why i gotta say about that but uh
no no um hey hey you know when you lose
an argument you gotta get pers
that's what's going on right here he
ain't gonna burst though he's going
first okay you're talking and you bought
it out showing your bot but anyway uh
the game uh again it needed it needed
new leadership and uh
hopefully things get better but
hopefully we never go down this route
again where this is a service
game and we actually learn
to drop at your content
uh you can't compare it splatoon 3 is a
good shooter and halo infinite is it
three years hundreds of millions of
dollars and it's with two three wiped it
out with ease you know what dirt he got
splatoon 3
to halo infinite it's like companion
ninja turtles to the avengers that was
crazy
now it's now subjective don't you love
how big cloud coming in here because he
just got he just got destroyed in the
argument
hold on let me say something to donald
trump right now let me say something
subjective y'all see this live he said
splatoon 3 is a good shooter and halo if
it isn't that's subjective right that's
subjective right so first off comparing
splatoon 3 the halo infinite is like a
parent teenage mutant ninja turtles sort
of avengers now you bro you can't you
can't in this stream in this no bro it's
a kitty cute kv game where you're
shooting paintballs
come on man are you shooting paintballs
are you just shooting paint i thought it
was just i don't know what it is it's
paint
hey you know what they're better
platoon
imagine playing imagine playing splatoon
3 when you shot
instead of paint it was just a bunch of
dirt griggitys coming out of the cup
all over people flipping the bird there
you go flame wild he said i stand with
don halo got inked by three four three
come on
let's make sure the mafia police are
happy we
we one minute one hour 52 minutes and 30
seconds man so go ahead and get your
outros man yo hey you got a super chat
from slo-mo uh
oh god sooner you want me to read it i
can read it you want me to
infinite seems to be riding the ship but
it's going to be a long time before we
see results are players willing to wait
if not should they just move on to
halo 7. in my opinion they need clean
slate bro halo infinite isn't like uh
the worst game of all time y'all acting
like it was it's like the worst game of
all time or something like this it just
stop and start over
no i don't think it's in that condition
where it needs to start over
i think that they can recover the brand
but i think the best move would probably
be making a new game uh so
where where can the people find you at
man what's going on with you
oh man just uh you know having a little
fun man you know
um just been talking some trash on
social media i don't be on twitter that
much because twitter you know just you
live on social media i saw it on twitter
you never saw me
no so stop by check out my channel you
know it's uh you know you know we're
having fun man so that's about it pony
slayer you beat them twitter
put put your p put your twitter in the
trap man put your twitter in the chat
or your youtube channel on twitter i put
my youtube in the chat man stop by and
check it out guys
this is funny
if you want extra stuff man that that's
that's where you do man that's
funny podcast man funny podcast and big
clown coming back
from the police placement surgery
you're only looking at aesthetics it's
more technical than halo infinite has
more content and a thought out roadmap
splatoon 2 still has more players than
infinite so between three equals 10
million first
he's saying you know he's saying for you
for you to roll over it's overdone don't
nobody give a damn about no splatoon
listen to yourself don it's all about
you
you're hyping up again this game is
better you can shoot pain everywhere
billion dollar franchise thank you oh my
god you heard him dawg no further
questions get on you heard them dawg
until they get they until they get their
bank account right they can't come to
the big boy conversation
they have the kitty table us man
you can shoot paint everywhere look at
the colors
all right
big clouds what is happening i don't
even know what's happening big cloud
where where where can the people find
you since you just got your knees
surgery you know you came back it got
that that you zero and one with the chat
today it's okay you come back next week
and get that
[ __ ] don't but okay uh
no maybe we could put a poll but
you know
appreciate it uh
spent a minute just got my uh package
from uh elgato so we're setting that
stuff up it's gonna be funny i'm gonna
try to be confetti
but i know it's a big cloud youtube
twitch twitter 49 yards uh
put in
all right got a five dollar super chat
i'll put yeah put your twitter in there
man uh put your twitter in there spam it
i want you both to spam man flame with
the five dollars here until splatoon has
a bad non-canon show it won't be on the
same level as han uh halo
uh slayed on slay oh
they
they they they cut they're coming
together man they they look in the end
during today his whole day
man i don't give a damn i know splatoon
y'all should look in the mirror we are
typing it
[Laughter]
y'all should y'all should look in the
mirror as an adult why y'all
actually get your phone
and put your
your selfie on your selfie camera look
and look look at yourself while you as a
grown man typing what you're saying
right now
hey i think we can all agree that
splatoon 3 even played on nintendo
crappy network it's still a better
experience than anything sony has
produced wow
yo
[Applause]
got these guys going crazy man
dirk going crazy
all right so you know you know i
appreciate everyone coming through
we had a great show it was a fun show uh
i will say that we had 36 votes at the
end who won today big cloud
and the dude who won got 72 percent so
that was funny 33 people and hold on
what'd you say where's the shot where'd
you do it where's the spoiler uh
it's it's on youtube hey yo slow-mo show
some respect slow-mo he talking about
splatoon gonna play puts halo infinity
to shane hey
hey slow-mo show some respect yeah
that's funny
oh my god you guys you guys are great
right i really appreciate all the
support you guys show today we add up to
like 300 people 330 340. hit that like
button you guys your way out man we'll
see you next week